[Music]
enough morbid curiosity let's have
matthew mcconaughey advertise us i need
to see this uh ladies and gentlemen if
you're maybe listening to this in public
just for warning you may get wet yeah
you may get wet
face
[Music]
space
okay the boundary of human achievement
yeah i guess it is a boundary
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it's not time to
escape it's time to engage
it's time to plant more trees
[Music]
it's time to build more trust
time to make more space
for all of us
so while the others look to the
metaverse and mars let's stay here and
restore ours
yeah it's time to blaze our trail
because the new frontier
it ain't rocket science
it's right here
[Music]
sponsored by salesforce salesforce what
the [ __ ]
that was actually a good ad yeah yeah
it wasn't bad
but what is it for team earth yeah what
is team earth oh i'm glad you asked
because there's a link right there on
the end card oh gee we can find out yeah
let's learn more team earth
has sign up for salesforce and take
advantage of team earth our new zoom
like application okay oh god oh my god
[Laughter]
our renewable energy zoom
competitor oh [ __ ] god damn it is
this an actual like sales force thing
though
yeah what do they do
i hate i hate big corporations like this
look what does that say go back up
look at this our people our planet
that's our business that's our business
no your business is crm software that's
your business has nothing to do with the
environment
look sparking change with innovation
what the [ __ ] does that mean yeah
explain it just use plain english hey we
have a lot of money and we're going to
try to do this thing with it join team
earth how do i join what do i do what is
this pledge to share your success is
this a charity is this a facebook group
what is this draft an actionable climate
plan
build with intention oh is this some
[ __ ] [ __ ] app for like people who
actually care about the earth and do
things keep scrolling keep scrolling it
helps them do that
no i don't think so join the
conversation that's what you're supposed
to do oh god okay i'm pretty sure this
is a hashtag that's what this is that's
all it is it's a hashtag
that's the only concrete thing on this
page
sick
sweet ad dude yeah
what was that ad for just to be like no
don't go to space
work for us here yeah okay dude don't go
to space we need you all yeah no no no
don't sell your apes yeah don't sell
them don't leave don't leave come on
stay here yeah i thought you were a
diamond hands earth boy come on if you
want to go to space don't go to space we
need you go to the metaverse what's
going on with facebook
crm software
peter thiel is stepping down or whatever
yeah he's no longer on the board of
facebook why is that significant i don't
know i think it's kind of indicative of
what everyone's been saying that this is
the beginning of the end for facebook
they set a record on friday for the most
market cap ever lost
in one day the most value ever lost in
one day they lost 200 billion dollars of
value when their stock dropped like 22
percent uh because um
neil young took his [ __ ] off of facebook
as well
yeah right
yeah you see neil young
put it on amazon yeah so [ __ ] good
so good
oh my god
um
yeah i think it's it's
have you been on instagram recently it's
just all reels now yeah they just are
hammering reels for some reason yeah
it's because tick tock is stealing so
much attention from instagram it's over
it's that plus the fact that apple
doesn't allow them to track anymore
um so they lost a bunch of revenue 10
billion dollars
they lost through that yeah
that's basically funneled directly to
google because people can't buy search
traffic on facebook anymore because they
can't target ads as well but google
still can so all that companies that are
advertising on instagram now go to
google instead
they're just [ __ ] on facebook it's
hilarious yeah they're like yeah no
we're the we're the cool kid tech crew
and you're just the the reject even
after all that mark you're still a dork
and and plus the rebrand everyone's like
well this is still not a thing yeah the
metaverse isn't real yet so it's a
pretty huge bet on something that's
probably not going to happen it's also
just not going to happen because that
[ __ ] exists already like i feel like the
clients for [ __ ] vr have been found
unless you're going to put vr in a set
of ray-bans that cost 200
and it doesn't make you want to vomit
like there's not gonna be mass adoption
for goddamn the metaverse nothing is
going to get better than world series of
poker on metaverse yeah that's the best
you can't get better than that so i love
showing people my car already exists
yeah exactly yeah it's so great that
they hide them yeah
what am i holding
that's what i mean it's the best yeah
although i guess apple is working on a
headset yeah but theirs will be you know
actually good
well they'll just figure out a way to
get their customers into it it's gonna
be [ __ ] up when you walk in the living
room and your mom was just in there like
have you played this poker stars on vr
yeah
listen i'm gonna need some help i'm i
need some money
[Laughter]
join the movement guys team earth make
sure you hashtag that on all the
comments that you leave on this on
patreon make sure you're hashtagging
team earth so we know you're on the team
yeah i'm gonna pee in public and hashtag
it as t team earth yeah
just you know keeping things
i'm not gonna
you know
fuel [ __ ] uh
big toilet industry you know using power
to flush water and
[ __ ] on the ocean yeah team
team fertilizer yeah you know team earth
earth
[ __ ] on the grass
team earth
i i
i use a lot of plastic
you know i'm not
i'm not too too good at recycling but i
don't [ __ ] with space so does that make
me team earth and my team because i am
team earth i like earth way better than
what's out there yeah i'll still buy a
six pack of beer with the thing with the
turtle chokers on it yeah i'll still buy
that yeah and i'll throw it in the ocean
i like to i like i go to the venice beer
and i throw it guys
i save all my plastic things with the
six i buy cans six pack of cans on
purpose yeah and i save the plastic
things i go to the pier and i toss them
off you know the industry term for that
thing is actually a turtle noose
is it yeah yeah yeah actually when they
pitched it originally to coca-cola the
guy who came up with it that was the
first who's initially supposed to be
something that killed her yeah he was
just like well i made this to kill
turtles and they're like wait a minute
but it also doubles for soda cans which
is great because people will take these
to the beach and then the turtles will
still die yeah yeah that way you can
take a cold six-pack out on a boat
finish the six-pack and then you can use
that chocolate turtle or something you
just snatch up a couple yeah yeah
everything's [ __ ] mm-hmm it's not just
the turtles yeah we're done we're dying
too what's your favorite way to get
micro plastics asbestos
you